[Musik]
hier ist das einkaufszentrum gagarin für
informationen drücken sie die 1 um mit
der geschäftsleitung zu sprechen
guten morgen ich habe einige dokumente
für alle europe und sie haben mir diese
adresse gegeben
vávrová allee 3 aber das ist ein
einkaufszentrum
[Musik]
die ersten beiden nächte habe ich vor
anders geschlafen ich hatte angst weil
ich in dem arbeitsvertrag der ich
unterschrieben hatte meine adresse meine
telefonnummer meine passnummer und meine
kontonummer angegeben hatte
[Musik]
sie sagten sie wüssten wo ich wohne dass
sie meine telefonnummer und meine
ip-adresse hätten und am nächsten tag
schrieben sie mir das mein leben von nun
an immer komplizierter werden würde wenn
ich meinen auftrag nicht bis 17 uhr
desselben tages erfüllt hätte
matthias hecker und digitale geldkuriere
[Musik]
ich habe viele jahre im verkauf
gearbeitet und letztes jahr meinen job
verloren diese kuba laos kurs ich sah
diese anzeige für einen teilzeitjob es
war angegeben dass ich von zu hause aus
arbeiten kann damit hatte er bin
definitiv
man brauchte einen internetanschluss ein
mobiltelefon und einen computer
die bedingungen waren ungefähr vier
stunden pro tag für 2200 euro
das ist nicht viel aber auch nicht zu
wenig
es hätte jedem passieren können aber es
passierte dieser frau die wir zu ihrer
sicherheits katja ronchi nennen werden
eine ehemalige verkaufs angestellte aus
der gegend von lugano auf der suche nach
einem job ihr leidensweg begann im
september 2009 10
ich sage diese anzeige auf der plattform
des seco des staatssekretariats für
wirtschaft namens lawrow
[Musik]
weil die regionalen arbeitsamt jedem
arbeitslosen mitglied ein passwort geben
mit dem sie die auf der plattform
veröffentlichten stellenangebote
überprüfen können ich nahm also an dass
es sich um ein ernsthaftes angebot
handelte die unternehmen die das inserat
veröffentlichten real estate villa und
co mit sitz in paradiso und real estate
plus gmbh in lüsslingen
also waren es zwei verschiedene firmen
die beiden unternehmen arbeiten zusammen
weil auf der website einige villen im
tessin im supply chain risotto chenery
angegeben waren
auf der website wurde auch ein
zertifikat der eidgenossenschaft erwähnt
ein qualitätszertifikat von real estate
villa und co
es kam ihnen also vertrauenswürdig vor
ja eine vertrauenswürdige sache ich
spreche nicht sehr gut deutsch also habe
ich eine online software genutzt um die
anzeige zu übersetzen kommen die
aufgaben erschien mir gut es ging um
datenverarbeitung und computer
speicherung
bevor sie die bewerbung ab schickte rief
katja das unternehmen an um weitere
informationen zu erhalten
ich sprach mit einer dame die sagte ihr
name sei million
sie sprach deutsch ich sprach englisch
sie sagte ich müsse jeden tag meine e
mails abrufen meine aufgaben überprüfen
und sie im laufe des tages erledigen
aufgaben wie bearbeitung von dokumenten
möglicherweise die archivierung ich
hätte zugang zu ihrer plattform also
nahm ich an es sei eine tessiner agentur
die ferienwohnung vermietet und verkauft
sie bewahrt sich also und reichte alle
geforderten unterlagen
einschließlich ihrer kontonummer nach
ein paar tagen erhielt sie zu ihrer
überraschung eine positive antwort und
der vertrag wurde ihr per e mail in
deutscher sprache zugesandt
[Musik]
und da meine deutschkenntnisse begrenzt
waren schickte ich den vertrag an meine
gewerkschaft um ihn überprüfen zu lassen
der mann zögerte einen moment und
seufzte ich spreche kein deutsch ich
kann ihnen nicht helfen
also machte ich diese kopie pace übungen
mit einer online software und soweit ich
wusste sah er für mich in ordnung aus
ich war glücklich denn immerhin hatte
ich schon einen job gefunden
zwar nur einen teilzeitjob aber immer
noch besser als nichts und ich hatte die
möglichkeit eine andere sprache zu üben
und ein anderes gebiet auszuprobieren
die immobilienbranche ich dachte ich
würde ein bisschen besser deutsch lernen
man versucht die zeit der
arbeitslosigkeit so schnell wie möglich
zu beenden
auch weil wir verpflichtet sind
mindestens zwölf suchanfragen pro monat
zu stellen jede art von arbeit
unverzüglich anzunehmen
ich hatte also angst dass ich wenn ich
die stelle nicht annehme mit strafen
überhäuft werde
hier wie konfetti beim karneval fallen
[Musik]
ein anderer kanton ein anderer
stellensuchender der in die gleiche
falle getappt ist nicht karl witti aus
freiburg hat jedoch einen vorteil er
spricht gut deutsch und hat im
personalwesen gearbeitet
ich wurde motiviert weil ich seit 2005
10 im ruhestand war
und nachdem ich zwei oder drei jahre
lang spaß an der gartenarbeit hatte
wollte ich mir eine nebenbeschäftigung
in dieser richtung suchen wo ich auch
unter menschen bin ich war es schon
immer gewohnt unter leuten zu arbeiten
auch dank des sports ich war lange zeit
fußball trainer lennart wurde die gage
die nur wohn und das hat mich veranlasst
wieder nach einer beschäftigung zu
suchen
und wie wollten sie einen job finden
ganz einfach ich habe meinen lebenslauf
aktualisiert und bin dann ins internet
gegangen ich erwähnte meine große
berufserfahrung dass ich es gewohnt bin
unter menschen zu sein und auch dass ich
es gewohnt bin menschen zu führen ich
habe alle meine unterlagen über meine
früheren berufserfahrungen beigefügt und
natürlich auch erwähnt dass ich nicht
karriereorientiert bin ich bin ja fast
der rentner war sich bewusst dass es ein
schwieriges unterfangen werden würde und
stellte sich der herausforderung auf
dieselbe anzeige zu antworten die
bereits das interesse von katar und
geweckt hatte
[Musik]
grundsätzlich war ich interessiert an
einem job zwischen 30 und 50 prozent
ich wollte keine festen arbeitszeiten
mehr haben also habe ich diesen
prozentsatz angegeben und dann ist mir
diese anzeige aufgefallen
für 2200 euro
ich dachte zwischen 30 und 50 prozent
für 2200 euro sei ideal gepresst oder
durch den gummi geht kann nur probieren
ich habe mich beworben und sie haben
ziemlich schnell geantwortet und gesagt
jawoll so etwas wie mich suchen sie
wissen sie wenn man drei jahre lang nach
einer stelle sucht ist es überraschend
wenngleich der erste oder zweite und
sagt genau so etwas wie sie suchen wir
danke gott für mich war das eine
freudige nachricht beigefügt war auch
gleich der arbeitsvertrag dann habe ich
gedacht okay das ist wahnsinnig schnell
in anbetracht meiner berufserfahrung
kamen mir dann aber doch zweifel ich
sagte mir hat er bietet auch keiner 2200
euro an ohne dich auch nur einmal
getroffen zu haben und meine kompetenzen
zu können und auch aufgrund meiner
früheren tätigkeit
geldwäsche bei postfinance sein großes
thema war kam mir das in den sinn
nick albert ii legte die dinge auf reis
er beschloss einige nachforschungen über
real estate los anzustellen und schrieb
eine weitere e-mail an den
personalleiter
[Musik]
ich habe dieser frau und niederhaus
geschrieben und ihr einige sehr direkte
fragen gestellt
die telefon- und mering dietgard unter
nissen wie kommt es dass ihre
telefonnummer nirgends zu finden ist ich
habe geschrieben fast bedeuten die
punkte vier und 4.3 im vertrag die sich
speziell auf die verpflichtungen bezogen
mund schrieb sie bieten mir über 26.000
euro pro jahr ohne mich kennenlernen zu
wollen und ich weiß seit ich bei
postfinance arbeitet wenn verträge
unterschrieben und dann eingescannt
werden dann ist das nicht gültig
wie man den kirchenweg 309 findet habe
ich noch gefragt und dem kirchenweg gab
es dort nur ein haus das architekturbüro
steiner
adriano kam gewinnt der rest des leeres
feld
[Musik]
was haben sie zu diesem zeitpunkt
gedacht die ich hatte ein starkes gefühl
dass da irgend etwas seltsam war und ich
dachte ich rufe besser diesen herrn
steiner an
[Musik]
ein kluger schachzug denn pascal steiner
der besitzer
hatte nicht nur keinen job zu vergeben
sondern war selbst opfer von etwas
geworden dass sich immer mehr als mega
betrug herausstellte für mich hat die
geschichte so bekommen dass sich
seltsame anrufe bekam
von leuten die eine stelle sucht
ihr war klar da muss irgendetwas schief
laufen weil ich keine mitarbeiter suchte
und auch sonst niemand der in meiner
firma arbeitet oder drogen elasthan
zuerst habe ich auch keinen verdacht
geschöpft ich sagte den leuten einfach
es handelt sich wahrscheinlich um ein
irrtum und sie sollen sich nicht mehr
melden geht erst später wurde ich auf
die kriminelle absicht aufmerksam als
sich von einem mann aus dem kanton
freiburg kontaktiert wurde der eine
stelle sucht
dieser mann schickte mir auch die
unterlagen und den arbeitsvertrag in den
der firmenname übernommen wurde war die
resta tory premiers uta
in den ersten zwei wochen erhielt ich am
tag vielleicht ein oder zwei anrufe
später stellte ich fest dass diese
gefälschte stellenanzeige auf viele
plattformen aufgeschaltet wurde suzuki
wird bevor auf und dann wurden aus ein
oder zwei anrufe am tag zehn bis 15
es war für mich echt stressig denn ich
musste ja meiner eigenen arbeit
nachgehen und
wie viele leute haben insgesamt
angerufen
ungefähr 70
so fand der architekt heraus dass jemand
angeblich hacker eine website unter dem
namen seiner firma erstellt hatte
und er erstattete sofort anzeige
die meisten anrufe kamen aus der
ostschweiz gefolgt von freiburg bern
solothurn
so lebte und natürlich aus dem tessin
das gespräch war immer das gleiche ich
musste aufpassen und freundlich sein
denn ich hatte die beherrschung
verlieren kann whatever kapitalisieren
ich musste arbeiten jedenfalls habe ich
immer versucht kurz zu erklären dass die
anzeige gefälscht war die meisten haben
das sofort verstanden sie fanden die
anzeige auch irgendwie komisch und
verdient geld indem man nichts tut man
muss nichts können das war irgendwie
verdächtig
und die meisten sagten ja das ist mir
klar es
[Musik]
gibt telefonate die mich besonders
berührt
ein anruf kam von einem mann der den
vertrag schon unterschrieben hatte er
hatte den betrügern seinem konto daten
zur verfügung gestellt und eine
überweisung von zehntausenden von
schweizer franken erhalten und dann
wurde er massiv bedroht damit er das
geld an eine bestimmte adresse schickt
ich gehe davon aus dass es natürlich um
geldwäsche ging mir ist aufgefallen dass
viele der beteiligten personen nicht
sehr gut deutsch oder eine andere
landessprache beherrschen
und wahrscheinlich nicht einmal den
vertrag gut lesen konnten
herausfanden dass der text so viele
rechtschreibfehler enthielt dass er
zumindest sehr verdächtig war
das ist missbrauch denn die menschen
handeln ja aus einer schwäche heraus
wie ich heute gerade feststellen musste
sind die anzeigen immer noch im netz zu
finden diese geräte wir haben versucht
diese plattformen zu stoppen aber es ist
schwierig weil sie meist im ausland
aktiv sind
es ist wie ein katz-und-maus-spiel mann
beantragt die löschung auf einer
plattform und sie wird auf einer anderen
wieder veröffentlicht und das ist ein
problem
wir sind praktisch machtlos gegen diese
missbräuchliche verwendung unseres
namens und solange das so weitergeht
können wir gar nichts mehr machen man
fühlt sich wirklich missbraucht man
nimmt uns im grunde eine solide firma
mit all ihren hintergründen der buße und
man kann nichts dagegen machen
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit ist ist uns gelungen
den anwalt des immobilienbüros in
paradiso zu kontaktieren das anscheinend
eine tochtergesellschaft von pascal
steiners firma ist in wirklichkeit
handelt es sich um zwei verschiedene
unternehmen die opfer des selben betrugs
geworden sind und selbst im fall des
maklerbüros im paradiso haben einige
bewerber nicht nur angerufen um
informationen zu erhalten sondern auch
direkt ihre unterschriebenen verträge
geschickt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der erste vertrag kam anfang april 2009
10 dieser zweite vertrag wieder im april
und der dritte kam im mai also
beschlossen wir etwas dagegen zu tun um
die angelegenheit bei der
staatsanwaltschaft anzuzeigen
die anhörung der staatsanwaltschaft fand
im juli statt haben sie sich gefragt
warum gerade der name ihres mandanten
geplant wurde
natürlich haben wir uns gefragt warum
sie diese firma gewählt haben aber wir
haben keine antwort auf diese frage
gefunden
den song imagine ob ich vermute dass es
unter anderem nach kriterien ausgewählt
wurde die wir nicht kennen
im juli an wir wissen nicht für welche
kriterien sich die verfasser diese
initiative entschieden haben der
initiative
vielleicht weil es nicht als unternehmen
tätig war
ich weiß es nicht offen gesagt sollten
sie diejenigen fragen die diese
entscheidung getroffen haben
was ist die firma real estate villa und
co
tessiner firma die nur eine immobilie
besitzt ihr einziger zweck ist es also
diese immobilie zu verwalten und zu
betreuen
wir wissen nicht nach welchen kriterien
die hacker die unternehmen
identifizieren deren namen sie stehlen
wollen aber anscheinend konzentrieren
sie sich auf kleine unternehmen die
keine web seite haben und daher sehr
attraktiv für die hacker sind die ein
schaufenster brauchen auf dem sie ihre
glaubwürdigkeit aufbauen können
wir haben beschlossen weiter zu gehen
und nach der anzeige zu suchen die katja
ronchi und nicole vetrih beantwortet
haben
die seite ist immer noch aktiv sie ist
grafisch identisch und sieht wie eine
perfekte kopie der vorherigen seite aus
zu diesem zeitpunkt haben wir uns mit
einem falschen namen beworben obwohl
sich zu unserer überraschung der name
des unternehmens geändert hat jetzt
heißt des alpha swiss real estate mit
sitz in lugano
ich hatte in der zwischenzeit gehofft
dass der erste auftrag bald kommt und
dann kam er sehr früh am morgen
ich bekam eine e-mail in der stand du
hast einen auftrag
in der nacht schickten sie eine summe
auf ein bankkonto auf dass sie mein
gehalt zahlen sollten
wir haben 11.400 schweizer franken
geschickt
holen sie es sich in bar und rufen sie
uns dann an
wenn möglich in 11.000 erscheinen und 2
200 erscheinen
eine gelinde gesagt fragwürdige e-mail
in der katja ronchi konkrete anweisungen
bekam sagen sie den angestellten dass
sie bargeld von ihrem girokonto abheben
wollen erwähnen sie nicht dass es für
das geschäft die arbeit oder einer
immobilie ist sagen sie dass es sich um
eine private transaktion für den
persönlichen gebrauch rates sie könnten
zum beispiel sagen dass sie das geld für
teure medikamente brauchen
und was haben sie gedacht
das ist merkwürdig war ich wollte es
herausfinden denn nach dem was ich in
den vorangegangenen telefonat
mitbekommen hatte hieß es dass es leute
gebe die ferienhäuser vermieden würden
ich habe also nicht verstanden warum sie
mir dieses geld geschickt haben ich
wollte es abheben und rief dann an um
die sache zu klären weil ich dachte ich
müsste eine anzahlung für eine wohnung
für jemanden live der in letzter minute
anreisen würde
ich fragte wofür das geld sei und sie
sagten ich würde innerhalb von zwei
stunden eine e-mail mit anweisungen zum
weiteren vorgehen erhalten
und dass sich das geld bei mir behalten
sollte
haben sie sie irgendwie unter druck
gesetzt
wenn ich meinen auftrag innerhalb von 24
stunden ausführen würde bekäme ich 90
euro extra und noch mehr geld und die
kosten zu decken im grunde wollten sie
dass dieses geld von ihrem konto
verschwindet es sollte sofort von meinem
konto abgehoben werden ja
das einzige was wir haben um
herauszufinden wer hinter diesen
digitalen betrug steckt sind die
adressen der webseiten auf denen die
stellenanzeigen veröffentlicht wurden
metronome die dominieren inter jedem
domainnamen stehen kontoinhaber und
provider als um die personen an die man
sich wendet um eigentümer eines
domainnamens zu werden wir können diese
daten die öffentlich sind einsehen und
herausfinden woher die besitzer einer
website die wir besuchen kommen
im fall von real estate plus wissen wir
dass sich die seiten physisch auf einem
computer befinden der auf einem server
in den niederlanden steht
er wird von einem unternehmen betrieben
dass diese art von service für alle
möglichen webseiten anbietet
völlig normal ich kann eigentümer einer
website sein die sich in luxemburg in
frankreich oder in den vereinigten
staaten befindet so ist das im internet
für sie gibt es noch andere
informationen die sie gesehen haben
viviano hier sehen wir wo sie
registriert wurde in diesem fall können
wir an diesem dort eu sehen dass sie bei
einem russischen dienstleister
registriert wurde
an sich ist das nicht illegal aber es
gibt uns an den hinweis auf die
entscheidungen die die leute getroffen
haben die website eröffnet haben es gibt
auch andere interessante hinweise die
uns eine vorstellung davon geben wer
hinter dieser art von geschäft stecken
könnte anstatt in einem einfachen text
zu schreiben wurde eine grafische
formulierung gewählt das ist ein in
diesem bereich sehr verbreiteter trick
um zu verhindern dass suchmaschinen wie
google die seite anzeigen wenn man nach
dem unternehmen sucht
das war die erste firma inzwischen sehen
wir aber dass es einen weiteren eintrag
geht der von einer firma namens alpha
swiss real estate
dass er interessante an dieser zweiten
domain ist dass sie die exakte kopie der
ersten das einzige was sich geändert hat
ist der grafische streifen in dem der
name der firma steht die sie imitieren
auch hier der gleiche trick die
verwaltung des website kurz ist
identisch die verlinkten dokumente sind
die gleichen
der einzige unterschied besteht darin
dass sich der server in der republik
moldau
im vorherigen fall haben wir die gleiche
stelle bei der der domainname
registriert wurde nämlich in
russland/gus ja aber stecken wirklich
dieselben leute hinter dieser anzeige
das können wir nicht mit sicherheit
sagen aber es ist ziemlich
wahrscheinlich ihre arbeitsweise ist
dieselbe die struktur der website ist
identisch einige seiten richten sich
nicht an die schweiz sondern zb an
norwegische kunde nur eins sie sind
genau dieselben wenn sie also denselben
weg gehen muss ich auch dieselbe weise
bewegen sind es wahrscheinlich dieselben
leute ich gehe davon aus dass es sich um
das übliche muster handelt eine bande
von betrügern die beschließt einen platz
auf einem server zu bekommen wenn nicht
blockiert zu werden nehmen sie mehrere
auf verschiedenen servern man sollte nie
alle eier in einen korb legen
auf diese weise sind die anderen server
die anderen websites immer noch aktiv so
dass der betrug an anderer stelle
fortgesetzt werden kann wenn sie zum
beispiel wegen des eingreifens der
behörden geschlossen werden
ich denke es ist ganz logisch anzunehmen
dass derjenige der eine solche aktivität
ins leben gerufen hat eine investition
tätigen wollte zwar eine illegale aber
dennoch eine investition so dass die
operation einen ertrag abwerfen muss
unter einer bestimmten größenordnung
macht eine solche operation keinen sinn
es handelt sich also sicherlich um 10
hunderttausende von schweizer franken
pro jahr
[Musik]
ein paar tage sind seit unserer online
bewerbung vergangen als wir eine e mail
erhalten
der absender ist ein züricher
unternehmen namens smart
support das uns einen job anbietet wir
haben die adresse überprüft aber es gibt
keine spur von einer solchen firma
diesmal haben die betrüger jedoch einen
deutlichen qualitätssprung gemacht und
eine homepage eingerichtet auf der sie
unter anderem die namen ihrer
angeblichen partnerfirmen angeben von
ubs über wrestling bis nie groß
wenn sie mit einem mitarbeiter der
personalleitung sprechen möchten drücken
sie die 1 wenn sie einen verstoß melden
wollen
[Applaus]
hallo willkommen bei one source ich bin
vincenzo wie kann ich ihnen helfen ja
guten morgen ist das support
nein sie haben die falsche nummer das
ist die firma sdr
aber diese nummer ist die nummer der
firma smart support in zürich
nein
vielleicht haben sie geändert das ist
unsere nummer wirklich wir sind nicht
diese firma wir sind es den der sie sind
es dr
es war bereits dezember als wir aus den
haag die nachricht von einer großen
polizei-razzia erhielten die von europol
durchgeführt wurde der name der
operation m5 european action against
money mules release balloni digital also
gegen hacker banden die menschen zwingen
geld zu waschen nicht weniger als 31
nationen waren an der razzia beteiligt
während der fünften europäischen geld
schmuggel aktion haben wir mehr als 3800
geld schmuggler identifiziert über 650
banken haben mit uns zusammengearbeitet
und ich denke das zeigt dass wir mit der
richtigen zusammenarbeit sehr
erfolgreich sein können kollaboration
mit emma 5 ist es uns gelungen auf der
grundlage der von uns ermittelten
transaktionen rund 13 millionen euro zu
blockieren die nicht in die hände von
kriminellen gelangt sind
cyberkriminelle zu fangen ist ziemlich
schwierig es gibt viele
herausforderungen die wir als
ermittlungsbehörden bewältigen müssen
wir haben auch große schwierigkeiten die
rechtssysteme der beteiligten länder
aufeinander abzustimmen
in der tat haben wir große probleme im
rechtlichen bereich wenn wir
rechtshilfeersuchen benötigen kann das
sehr lange dauern und die
rechtsgrundlagen sind nicht immer klar
wenn wir in verschiedenen ländern
arbeiten
und natürlich ist es zb bei der cyber
kriminalität sehr selten dass ein
verbrechen nur in der schweiz
stattfindet und dass sich das opfer der
kriminelle und die infrastruktur in
einem land befinden sie sind in der
regel über verschiedene länder verstreut
und werden vor den kriminellen oft so
ausgewählt dass sie in bestimmten
ländern stattfinden in denen die
rechtliche zusammenarbeit vielleicht
nicht so gut funktioniert wie in anderen
ländern
[Musik]
und nicht nur das im internet machen
hacker geschäfte mit dem organisierten
verbrechen
und es ist letzteres dass den hackern
die digitalen geldkuriere liefert um
geld zu waschen das von den bankkonten
ahnungsloser bürger gestohlen wurde
wenn ich zum beispiel als cyber
kriminelle oder hacker eine
verschlüsselungssoftware entwickelt habe
und einen angriff gestartet habe und die
zahlungen kommen rein und ich will das
geld waschen
die ideen die kuriere sind eine große
gruppe die über verschiedene länder
verteilt sind und sie erbringen die
dienstleistung sie das organisierte
verbrechen mehr anbietet die darüber in
saada das bedeutet dass ich mich als
hacker an die mafias wenden kann die
diese geld esel als reguläre
dienstleistung anbieten
juli kommission qualifiziert und wer
sind diese geld esel das sind im
regelfall personen die auf ein scheinbar
legales angebot reagiert haben zum
beispiel ein jobangebot in dem behauptet
wird sie könnten von zu hause aus
arbeiten einen bestimmten geldbetrag
verdienen und müssten lediglich ihr
konto für einige transaktionen zur
verfügung stellen ökologie der mittel
nur und dispositionen der delegation ich
auf ihr konto erhalten sie dann einen
betrag den sie weiterleiten müssen und
von dem sie wahrscheinlich einen kleinen
teil behalten können
an der europol razzia waren auch vier
kantone beteiligt zürich/basel watt und
aargau
auf den konten der schweizer
drogenkuriere wurden mehr als sieben
millionen euro gesperrt
175 geld esel wurden identifiziert und
264 opfer deren bankkunden geknackt
wurden und schließlich wurden 45
ermittlungen von den vier kantonalen
staatsanwaltschaften eingeleitet aber
die teilnahme an der operation war
freiwillig und das tessin hat sich
geweigert sich anzuschließen revision so
dass der fall katja ronchi noch offen
ist und wir wollen mehr herausfinden was
haben sie mit dem geld gemacht haben sie
es abgehoben und hierher gebracht
ja ich habe es mit nach hause genommen
zuerst dachte ich es sei ein schmutziges
geld der erlös aus dem verkauf der nicht
in den kreislauf gebracht werden konnte
[Musik]
denn selbst wenn nur zehn von uns auf
diese anzeige antworten würden pro
person 11.000 franken jede woche die
mahner dann würden sie schnell zehn
millionen in bar machen oder
und woher kam das geld auf ihrem konto
das war noch eine reihe von zahlen und
der name
ubs ich hatte nicht vor sie anzurufen
und zu fragen
dieser ubs kunde war also das
vorgelagerte opfer dieses betrugs von
seinem konto hatten die hacker die elf
1400 franken gestohlen die auf das konto
von katja ronchi umgeleitet wurden
sie im moment sind einige der häufigsten
methoden um geld von einem girokonto zu
stehlen dieser mann kann zb den computer
infizieren dafür das homebanking
verwendet wird so dass der benutzer
seinem homebanking aufruft einen
normalen vorgang durchführt und nicht
weiß dass er über seine eigene webcam
dem bildschirm vieler laptops eingebaut
ist beobachtet wird
der betrüger wartet darauf dass der
benutzer geht übernimmt die kontrolle
über maus und tastatur und führt eine
weitere transaktion
das ist eine ausgefeilte technik aber es
gibt auch andere die hauptsächlich auf
psychologie beruhen sie erhalten zb eine
mitteilung in papierform und wieder
heißt es es gibt ein problem mit ihrem
konto wir haben es zu ihrer sicherheit
gesperrt der briefkopf sieht authentisch
aus bitte rufen sie diese nummer an der
kundenservice ist für sie da
das opfer ruft die nummer an die zwar
einem betrüger gehört aber offenbar eine
kundenbetreuung nummer ist
ein betrüger geht ran und gibt sich als
bankangestellter aus keine sorge wir
werden ihnen helfen das ist also ihre
kontonummer und das ist ihre pin richtig
normalerweise sagt das opfer am anderen
ende nein das ist es nicht das ist meine
pin
gibt sie dem betrüger
wir wissen nicht ob dies in unserem fall
passiert
wir konnten aber das opfer des betrugs
ausfindig machen einen herren aus zürich
er bestätigte zwar den sachverhalt
wollte uns aber kein interview geben
ebenso wenig wie die ubs die bank weil
er sich der notgroschen in luft
aufgelöst hatte wir mussten der einzigen
wirklichen spur in der hand unseres
zeugen folgen
wo sollte das geld denn hin das geld war
für einen herrn oleg orlow in moskau
bestimmt moskau
und sie wissen nicht ob er existiert
nein ich wollte nicht einmal nachschauen
weil ich so viel angst hatte dass sie
auch meinen datenverkehr überprüfen
würden indem sie mir gesagt hatten dass
sie meine ip-adresse haben
ja natürlich
[Musik]
die muskeln und welches
system presse was das dauert
[Musik]
etwa 97 98 gab es einen boom einen
richtigen goldrausch für russische
hacker rop yakuza laura de la cruz als
sie merkten dass sie mit hecking eine
menge geld verdienen konnten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
investigativer journalist ist ein star
auf seinem gebiet seit er einen
wichtigen aufsatz über russische hacker
und ihre zusammenarbeit mit dem kreml
veröffentlicht hatte war er ins visier
seiner gegner geraten so sehr dass wir
nicht einmal seinen computerbildschirm
filmen durften weil es zu riskant war
die zweite generation der hacker geht
auf die frühen 2000er jahre zurück
das waren leute die mit diesem system
bereits reich geworden waren
sie begannen sich in gruppen
zusammenzuschließen
die waren in einer weise organisiert die
eine italienische mafia banden erinnert
zu dieser zeit genossen die hacker eine
große freiheit da es in russland keine
speziellen gesetze zur unterdrückung
dieser art von aktivitäten gab es ist
so dass sie nicht strafrechtlich
verfolgt werden konnten
alle hacker mit denen ich in kontakt kam
erinnert sich an diese zeit als das
goldene zeitalter documenta den long
aber die wirkliche revolution war 2012
als die ersten cyberkriegs angriffe
unter dem kommando der russischen
behörden gestartet wurden
sie begannen junge und talentierte
universitätsstudenten zu rekrutieren um
sich mit einigen bereichen der
cybersicherheit zu beschäftigen
zur gleichen zeit begannen die ersten
experimente mit cyber angriffen
diese hacker sind viele einige hundert
hohen sie sind gezwungen für die
spezialeinheiten zu arbeiten wenn sie
nicht ins gefängnis wollen
normalerweise werden die hacker
gezwungen sich zu entscheiden dass sie
erwischt werden wenn sie große angriffe
auf russische banken oder russische
kunden verüben
danach werden sie in den meisten fällen
zu einer befragung vorgeladen zum
beispiel von den geheimdiensten der
russischen föderation oder in anderen
ministerien wo sie die wahl haben
entweder im gefängnis zu landen oder mit
dieser institution zu kooperieren
in der regel entscheiden sich fast alle
für eine zusammenarbeit und führen
verschiedene aufträge aus es kommt aber
auch vor dass einige von ihnen gegen
bezahlung bei größeren angriffen auf
einen anderen staat angeheuert werden
manchmal sind diese angriffe das werk
illegaler hacker ära die jagd landes
wenn ich das richtig verstehe bedeutet
das dass die geheimdienste diese hacker
für ihre eigenen zwecke einsetzen sie
aber in die konten anderer länder
einbringen lassen
genau unter den helfern die für die
spezialeinheiten arbeiten gibt es auch
solche die die sicherheitssysteme der
banken aus profitgründen aushebeln
die lupe
das cyber kriminalität von den behörden
geduldet zu werden scheint ist cyber
sicherheit heute ein milliardengeschäft
und in russland der unbestrittenen
heimat der hacker sind einige
internationale giganten aus dem boden
geschossen die sicherheitsgeräte für
unternehmen und privatpersonen anbieten
die ibi group gehört zu den ersten in
diesem bereich
[Musik]
entwickeln eine vielzahl von werkzeugen
um cyber angriffe durchzuführen
informationen zu stehen private
informationen wie bankkonten
kreditkarten und so weiter
in unserer agentur haben wir
festgestellt dass diese cyber
kriminellen ihre werkzeuge zunächst in
russland und anderen östlichen ländern
testen
nachdem sie zwei jahre lang angriffe in
russland durchgeführt haben ziehen sie
in europäische länder oder asiatische
region
es liegt also an einzelpersonen und
insbesondere an den banken ihre eigenen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen ständig zu
aktualisieren um cyber lecks zu
vermeiden
[Musik]
heutzutage geben banken und unternehmen
viel geld aus um ihre systeme zu
schützen
deswegen ist es im moment nicht einfach
menschen mit bestimmter malware
anzugreifen
außerdem verwenden bankensysteme zur
verhaltensanalyse ihre betrugsbekämpfung
systeme zu verbessern
sie kennen erkennen ob sich jemand in
ein konto eingeloggt und versucht hat
geld zu überweisen
die banken sind in der lage diese art
von ungewöhnlichem verhalten zu erkennen
und die überweisung von geld zu
verhindern
aber wie finden sie heraus ob es der
kontoinhaber ist der eine transaktion
durchführt oder ein krimineller
es sind die anzeichen dafür
also normalerweise bieten wir diese
dienste an die man sicheres banking und
sicheres portal nennt
diese systeme sammeln informationen über
das benutzerverhalten grund wenn sich
jemand anderes bei einem bankkonto
anmeldet vergleichen wir das verhalten
dieser speziellen episode mit allen
früheren verhaltensweisen des echten
kunden
und wenn wir etwas feststellen dass
anders ist geben wir die informationen
an die bank weiter informationen und die
bank kann sie in ihrem betrugsbekämpfung
system verwenden
was meinen sie mit verhalten
zb ihre tipp geschwindigkeit oder wie
sie den cursor bewegen
zb informationen über die ip adresse die
sich für den internetzugang verwenden
all diese informationen werden von
unseren systemen gesammelt und
analysiert können schweizer bankkunden
generell als sicher angesehen werden
im vergleich zu anderen ländern glaube
ich dass die schweizer banken sicher
sind
aber in diesem jahr haben wir verstöße
bei über 10.000 konten und kreditkarten
festgestellt die schweizer banken
gehören die patentiere banken
das haben wir mit unserem system
herausgefunden
mindestens 10.000 schweizer bankkunden
sind in diesem jahr betrogen worden
diese tatsache ist besorgniserregend da
es sich dabei um die verletzten konnten
handelt die von einer einzigen cyber
sicherheitsagentur entdeckt wurden wer
weiß vielleicht war auch der betrogene
ubs kunde in zürich unter ihnen
eine frage die wir auch den russischen
behörden gestellt haben doch wir
erhielten nie eine antwort fest steht
dieses geld sollte genau hier in moskau
ankommen in der wallufer allee 3 wo wir
ein rauszufinden glaubten ist in
wirklichkeit ein riesiges
einkaufszentrum
und wenn der umschlag hier ankam wer
sollte ihn dann abholen ist oleg kotov
wirklich der empfänger des geldes oder
ist es nur ein code name
guten morgen ich muss wissen wie ich
einen briefkasten mit dieser adresse
mieten kann kann ich mit ihnen darüber
sprechen mir wurde gesagt dass sie mir
die informationen geben können ich bin
ein unternehmer ich habe ausländische
kollegen und wir brauchen einen
briefkasten man sagte mir ich solle zu
ihrem einkaufszentrum kommen
die korrespondenz tarek ein büro haben
aber eine offizielle postanschrift für
unsere adresse für unsere korrespondenz
benötigen sind sie hier pächter
nein wir brauchen nur einen briefkasten
sie müssen einen mietvertrag haben um
unsere adresse zu bekommen wird die man
dann briefkasten geben
[Musik]
oleg zhukov ich weiß nicht
versuchen sie die geschäftsleitung zu
fragen
hallo hallo entschuldigen sie ich suche
oleg rudolf einen mieter können sie uns
etwas sagen sie sind der typ der vorher
angerufen hat glaube ich ich habe ihnen
schon gesagt das gibt es eine liste von
mietern die ich mir ansehen könnte
selbst wenn wir eine solche liste hätten
wie auch immer es gibt hier niemanden
mit diesem namen gibt es diesen
mitarbeiter wirklich nicht hier nein den
gibt es nicht
in unserer verwaltung gibt es niemanden
mit diesem namen
[Musik]
ich musste also das geld nehmen und es
nach moskau schicken
ich fand die sache natürlich sehr
seltsam um es mal so zu sagen
also habe ich versucht es hinauszuzögern
und herauszufinden was ich tun sollte
also schrieb ich e-mails und fragte
welche art von umschlag ich verwenden
sollte ein c4 oder 15 welche farbe
eigentlich habe ich das geld sofort an
den absender zurückgeschickt ich sagte
dass das geld nicht mehr gehöre und sie
es zurück schicken müssten ich musste
warten bis die bank wieder öffnete zwei
stunden später
sie leben alleine fühlen sie sich sicher
am anfang nicht ich habe sogar einige
freunde um hilfe gebeten ich habe meine
freunde gefragt
in den ersten beiden nächten habe ich
woanders geschlafen ich fühlte mich
nicht in der lage dazu
ich bekam einige bizarre sms und am
nächsten morgen schrieben sie mir eine
e-mail in der sie sagten sie hätten
einen vertrag unterschrieben
meine aufgaben seien klar und es gäbe
nichts illegales und sie hätten ihre
anwälte und mein leben würde von nun an
immer komplizierter werden
aber am tag davor bekam ich angst also
versuchte ich die kantonspolizei zu
kontaktieren und erstattete anzeige
[Musik]